hemos aprendido ya en los últimos vídeos
que si tenemos un sistema que tiene
presión constante o si estamos en un
ambiente con presión constante entonces
el cambio en la antártida es igual al
calor agregado al sistema y le pongo una
pequeña porque es presión constante así
que si tenemos una reacción a más ve que
nos produce nuestro cambio en la
antártida digamos si nuestro cambio
lenta al pie es decir
si ésta es negativa es menor que cero
sabemos que esta es una reacción
exotérmica y eso porque es otra vez
porque estoy suponiendo la presión
constante ahora sabemos que esto es
exotérmica porque estaré liberando
energía verdad esto cuando cuando
agregamos calor al sistema si bien al
final es negativo en realidad estamos
liberando calor verdad así que estamos
liberando calor o energía podemos
ponerle aquí o sumarle la energía y
hemos aprendido en el último vídeo o en
algunos vídeos anteriores que esto es
una reacción exotérmica
esta es una reacción exotérmica y si
tenemos una reacción que necesita
energía digamos que ahora tenemos más ve
y hay que sumarle cierta energía ok le
sumamos alguna energía y esto nos
produce entonces qué significa esto
bueno significa que el sistema ha
absorbido energía la cantidad de energía
que absorbe es tu cambio en la entalpía
así que nuestra delta h va a ser
positiva del touch es positiva hemos
absorbido energía y a estas reacciones
las llamamos endo térmicas
en dos térmicas estamos absorbiendo
calor ahora si queremos decidir o
predecir cuándo va a ser una reacción
espontánea ok
vemos que este cambio lenta al pie es un
buen candidato obviamente si estoy
liberando energía bueno pues no necesito
energía para que esto ocurra así que es
espontánea y por el contrario si yo
necesito energía mi intuición me dice
que quizás esto no es espontáneo pero
hay alguna pequeña parte que me dice
bueno qué tal si las partículas están
corriendo o están acelerando sé o qué sé
yo tienen mucha energía cinética goltz
se golpean unas a otras y de repente
pulso se vuelve espontánea quizás la
entalpía por sí misma no describe
completamente lo que va a pasar así que
para tener un poco de intuición déjenme
construir un poquito de sentido acerca
de estas o de lo que ocurre en estas
reacciones espontáneas así que pensemos
en los ingredientes
vamos a pensar bueno vamos a suponer que
liberamos energía es decir que el cambio
en lenta al pie es menor que cero y eso
pensar que va a ser espontáneo pero qué
tal si nuestra delta ese o si el cambio
en la entropía baja ok
qué pasa si las cosas se vuelven más
ordenadas ya hemos aprendido de otros
vídeos de termodinámica que ese no
tiende a ser el caso y en la experiencia
personal sabemos que esas cosas por su
propia cuenta casi no pueden ocurrir en
el estado macro verdad ya sabes es un
huevo no puede volverse a formar solito
después de abrirse no así que aunque hay
una pequeña probabilidad de que ocurra
así que parece que la entropía de alguna
forma importa un poquito y debido a que
ya hemos hablado un poco de esto de la
energía ok sí sí yo requiero energía
quizás la temperatura si es muy alta
estas partículas están corriendo muy
rápido y eso va a crear energía del otro
lado así que vamos a pensar vamos a
aterrizar todas estas ideas con los
ingredientes que ya tenemos qué pasa con
las reacciones que a través de distintas
combinaciones podrían generarse de forma
espontánea así que vamos a proponer
el cambio en la entropía
y también que nuestro cambio la entropía
puedan tener distintos signos así que
pensemos que el libera o absorbe energía
y por el lado de la entropía si se
vuelve más o menos ordenado
y vamos a tener también la temperatura
así que pensemos en el primer caso vamos
a pensar en la situación donde delta h
es menor que cero es decir que el cambio
en la entropía es negativa y que el
cambio en la entropía va a ser positiva
mi intuición me dice que algo va a
suceder esta situación donde vamos dejar
un lugar más en trópico después de una
reacción así que estoy mirando digamos
está esta dirección pensemos en las
partículas que tenemos así que podríamos
tener una reacción en donde en donde
digamos que tenemos por ejemplo este
tipo de partículas aunque este tipo de
moléculas digamos que tenemos ese tipo
porque este tipo que tiene a otro
naranjita y encima y que tenemos otro
tipo de moléculas digamos este azul
clarito que está unido a esta rosa
entonces digamos que que bueno no va a
decir en términos de estable o inestable
pero digamos que cuando estos dos chocan
ok cuando chocan el uno con el otro
terminamos con esto
digamos que estoy estoy inventando me
esto así que quizás una de estas
moléculas de azul fuerte estas se
separan digamos una de ellas se pega con
el azul claro
y este se pega con el rosa y quizás el
naranja se queda solito así que fuimos
de un lugar donde teníamos dos moléculas
a tener tres moléculas así que tenemos
más desorden más entropía esto
obviamente puede tomar más estados y
estamos suponiendo que la del touch es
menor que cero así que al hacer esto
estos tipos chocan liberan electrones y
energía potencial y al final terminan en
una configuración donde donde a lo mejor
se vuelven más estables y entonces
liberan energía así que tenemos de este
lado que sumarle y no sólo esto desde el
inicio me cambio la entropía es menor
que cero así que debe haber cierta
energía
cierta energía hay que sumarle así que
parece bastante obvio que esta reacción
va a ser espontánea en esta dirección
verdad porque no hay ninguna razón por
la cual bueno en principio es más fácil
para estas dos partículas chocar una con
otra y dirigirse en la dirección hacia
la derecha para producir estos esta
estas moléculas ok estas tres moléculas
que si pensamos que del lado derecho va
a regresar verdad estos están en un
estado potencial más bajo y por lo tanto
son más estables así que no hay ninguna
razón en tal pica para regresar en la
otra dirección ok
así que esto para mí tengo al menos de
intuición de que no importa la
temperatura nos va a favorecer esta
reacción en una dirección
ok
así que esto sin duda va a ser
espontánea
ahora qué ocurre vamos a hacer algo que
quizás sea menos intuitivo qué ocurre si
mi delta h es menor que cero pero
digamos que pierdo entropía es así que
como verás ya vimos de la segunda ley de
la termodinámica si dentro que la
entropía del universo sube pero digamos
que perdemos entropía ok podría ser una
situación donde voy de digamos dos
partículas
digamos que tengo esta partícula y esta
otra y entonces chocan ok
a lo mejor estarán compartiendo
electrones van a ser más estables pero
se unen de esta forma ok y cuando hacen
esto los electrones pueden entrar en
estados potenciales más bajos y entonces
tenemos que agregar energía de este otro
lado y eso lo tenemos porque el camión
lenta al pie es negativo y entonces es
una reacción exotérmica tenemos menos
energía en este estado que en el inicial
así que hay que liberar energía de
alguna forma ahora qué va a pasar con
esta reacción bueno parece si
introducimos nuestra temperatura que es
lo que va a pasar a bajas temperaturas a
bajas temperaturas estos dos tienen un
promedio muy bajo de energía cinética
sólo se están arrastrando de forma muy
lenta no se esté con mucha pereza y
recordemos que cuando hablamos de
espontaneidad
allí escribí mal esto verdad dice quién
sabe qué dice ahí pero en realidad quise
decir
montané a aunque este término sería otra
cosa y parece muy chistoso en fin
entonces donde estábamos era que sí
sí donde me quedé así si teníamos una
una si queremos una reacción espontánea
ok que esto ocurra por sí misma no estoy
hablando de qué tan rápido va la
reacción
esa es una clave importante no me
importa cuánto te tomes y mucho tiempo
poco tiempo sólo quiero saber cuando
estos dos chicos realmente van a
producir por sí mismos se van a chocar
se van a unir iban a producir
eventualmente otra molécula van a
reaccionar no me importa si va a tardar
diez mil años o si va a ocurrir en un
segundo ok
así que para bajas temperaturas lo que
lo que tenemos es que van a tratar de a
lo mejor no sé pasar muy cerca a darse
la mano y entonces se unen en una nueva
molécula ok los electrones se configuran
a sí mismos para obtener este nuevo
estado y además liberan energía otra vez
la energía se va en forma de calor o lo
que sea pero es difícil regresar en la
otra dirección
así que esto parece que también es
espontánea para temperaturas bajas
para temperaturas bajas puede ser
espontáneo
si la temperatura es baja por supuesto y
ahora qué ocurre si la temperatura es
muy alta aunque si la temperatura es muy
alta recordemos que estás bueno déjenme
poner más partículas en realidad estamos
hablando de propiedades macro de las
moléculas así que hay que no es no son
sólo unas partículas ok no tienen
sentido las variables macro ward para
sistemas micro así que qué ocurre si la
temperatura de nuestro sistema es muy
alta
así que pensemos de una situación donde
la temperatura es muy alta ahora todo
esto ocurre de este lado de la izquierda
ya sabes estarán chocando las partículas
muy muy rápido y estos van tan rápido
que apenas si se alcanzan a ver es como
si dos carros colisionaran no sí como si
dos carros chocarán sí sí es una buena
analogía si si cada uno de estos
individuos choca como en un carro ya
sabes están chocando unas a otras no no
es como están atados de alguna forma
pero al chocar se deshacen los carros
verdad no importa que tengan mucho
pegamento
mejor en los materiales serán muy
fuertes simplemente se va a despedazar
así que la energía cinética déjenme de
dibujar eso si tienen mucha energía
cinética mi intuición me dice que de
este lado de la reacción estos van a
regresar a la versión original de la
reacción del lado izquierdo porque van
tan rápido que cuando chocan se
desprenden unos a otros verdad se van a
desprender y entonces podemos ir del
lado derecho al lado izquierdo donde los
electrones tienen alguna estabilidad en
su configuración o qué sé yo imaginemos
que queremos atar por ejemplo ahora un
carro que va muy rápido ok entonces no
sé quizás la analogía ya no es tan buena
yendo de izquierda a derecha pero si
tenemos dos tipos que van muy rápido y
que van a ir chocando a lo mejor si
pasan muy cerca simplemente van tan
rápido que no son capaces de atarse él
unos a otros
ok ahora mi sentido me dice que si la
temperatura es muy alta decimos bueno
del lado izquierdo si estamos a muy
altas temperaturas entonces quizá estos
estas moléculas van chocando ok
por ejemplo y entonces se van
desprendiendo de esta forma a sus no sé
quizás incluso a sus formas elementales
el punto es que no vamos a regresar al
estado de la derecha así que ésta no va
a ser espontánea
ok y más aún la reacción en reversa es
probable que sí sea espontánea si la
temperatura es suficientemente alta para
que reaccionen choquen y entonces se
empiecen a desprender las moléculas ok
si la temperatura es alta si es
espontánea y si la temperatura es baja
podemos ir de forma espontánea de
izquierda a derecha ok
podemos tener mucha sensación de alguna
fórmula que nos pueda predecir la
espontaneidad a partir de estos ejemplos
déjenme empezar por ejemplo con la
entropía si esto por ejemplo es menor
que cero ya sabemos que esto va a ser
espontáneo no fue el primer ejemplo que
tuvimos ok entonces necesitamos una
expresión en donde con bueno si esta
expresión es menor que cero va a ser una
reacción espontánea y ahí va a estar
involucrada el cambio en la entalpía ok
si ahora consideramos la entropía vimos
en esta situación de aquí que si la
entropía es positiva siempre tenemos
como algo espontáneo verdad del lado
derecho
ahora queremos que toda nuestra
expresión sea negativa sí para que se
espontánea verdad así que mi entropía
positiva debería darle a toda mi
expresión
vamos a algo más negativo entonces vamos
a restarle la entropía si esto es
positivo toda mi expresión será negativa
eso me dice que esto es espontáneo y
esto corresponde al primer caso que
hicimos ok cuando el camión entra pies
positiva se lo resta y si el cambio en
la dental pie es negativa entonces
tenemos que toda expresión es negativa y
eso nos diría de alguna forma que se
espontánea ahora qué ocurre si la
entropía es negativa cuando la entropía
sne es es negativa hace que la reacción
sea menos espontánea verdad en esta
situación la entropía era negativa y
vamos de más desorden a menos desorden
oa menos partículas y que decíamos bueno
cuando la temperatura es alta la
entropía importa muchísimo
ok cuando la temperatura es alta la
entropía importaba mucho cuando la
temperatura es alta es este estado menos
en trópico se volvía más en trópico
cuando la temperatura es baja quizás
solo se va moviendo muy lento uno
y después la parte de la entropía de la
ecuación era la que importaba así que si
cuando la temperatura es alta la
entropía importa cuando la temperatura
es baja la entropía no importa qué tal
si solo escalamos la entropía por
nuestra temperatura es decir si
multiplicamos por la temperatura aquí
ahora afirmó o mintió o lo que está
basado en mi intuición de lo que hemos
experimentado me dice que esta expresión
si es menor que cero entonces deberíamos
estar trabajando con una reacción
espontánea ok ahora vamos a ver si esto
funciona con todo lo que hemos dicho si
la temperatura es alta así que esta
reacción de aquí dijimos que era
exotérmica en la dirección hacia la
derecha que si vamos hacia la derecha de
estas moléculas de hunts se van juntando
para hacer
otra verdad entonces estos tipos van a
irse moviendo lentamente si la
temperatura es baja por ejemplo y
entonces a temperatura baja este término
no va a importar mucho y puedes imaginar
el extremo cuando estamos en el cero
absoluto este realmente no pinta ok y
quien domina es el término de la del
touch ahora a altas temperaturas este
término es el que va a dominar nuestra
delta ese es menor que cero
y entonces todo este término va a ser
dominado y volverse positivo cuando le
estamos restando algo negativo en
realidad lo tenemos positivo y al
multiplicar por la temperatura es
positivo así que recordemos que cuando
estamos trabajando con grados kelvin en
la temperatura siempre es positiva y
entonces va a ser mucho mayor que el
delta h que es negativa verdad si la
temperatura es suficientemente alta
entonces hacia la derecha no va a ser
espontáneo en esta ocasión y si vamos
por ejemplo a donde la en tal pie es
negativa y el cambio en la entropía es
positiva entonces estamos liberando
energía verdad y nuestra entropía está
incrementando así que estamos
volviéndonos más desordenados y todo
esto es negativo y ya hemos tenido este
esta intuición de que bueno estos dos
términos son negativos verdad ya que el
primero era negativo y el segundo con el
signo menos es negativo así que hasta
ahorita esta ecuación nos dice que si es
negativo entonces es por esa espontánea
verdad esta ecuación nos predice la
espontaneidad de una reacción y vamos a
hacer esta demostración de forma un poco
más rigurosa ok
utilizando algunas fórmulas
fundamentales de entropía y demás por
esta fórmula nos dice algo de la
espontaneidad de la reacción ok y esta
cuando esta cantidad justo de aquí es
llamada delta g o el cambio en la
energía libre de jeeps y esto es lo que
predice cuando una reacción es
espontánea en el próximo vídeo voy a
aplicar esta fórmula aún varias veces y
después vamos a hacer un poquito más
de cómo podríamos usar estos principios
termodinámicos